I want to jump to this uh this tweet
here and talk about the next uh story
and the crumbling of society James Woods
real James Woods on Twitter says to the
whiners who criticize the defender
ending the deadly threat in a previous
video here's an example of the
consequences of being defenseless to
today's Predators you choose
this is a viral video it's a story from
uh just I think a few weeks ago a woman
worked at a cell phone store and a man
walked in oh
and she said how can I help you and he
said do you have and then just started
brutally beating her and I believe
trying to kill her yeah he was stomping
as hard as he could on her head she
escaped she was seriously hurt we have
this story from the Daily Mail
shocking moment thugs exchange gunfire
on busy New York City street in the
middle of the day repeated gang members
shot in the shoulder as an unidentified
gunman remains on the loose then we have
this one
NYPD hunt for two thugs after 61 year
old man is sucker punched and killed
while walking down a Brooklyn Street
near his home plays investigating
possible drug robbery
punched him in the face one time and he
was dead yeah that's all it takes that's
why that woman in the first video is is
absolutely lucky to still be alive the
damages that she sustained will probably
be with her for a very long time might
be with her for the rest of her lives
when you stomp someone on the ground on
their head so many people die from that
from physical altercations and and the
one thing but the issue here is the
crime itself the attack is one attack
what I'm trying to bring up is in all of
these major cities in New York
especially
crime has been insane we had that young
woman on the upper west side walking
home with a bunch of young boys just
stabbed their death right she tried
running she escaped they grabbed her
again and just started stabbing her
again homicides in San Francisco went up
11 it's almost like if you uh advocate
for defunding the police that crime will
go up
I think what we're seeing is a
demoralization
the good cops were quitting yeah but
also the cities themselves are just
breaking down for a variety of reasons
the increases in crime is due to a lot
of things yeah it's it's it's due to
these DA's that won't prosecute
that's why Chessa Boudin or harpercons's
name is get he got recalled because
people were like well they won't do
anything about it back to the streets
right it's all in the name of this woke
Equity being fair and just I mean like
this you have some of these people who
have been caught committing the crime
and they're letting them go and a lot of
these criminals know that they could
beat someone up they could hurt they
could do whatever they want to the
population there because they can't
defend themselves in New York City
almost every Common Sense form of
self-defense is is not allowed whatever
tools you could have to to protect
yourself you can't have in New York city
so a lot of people are talking about
poverty a lot of people are talking
about single parent homes here I I I
think the the true problem is I mean how
do you quantify this what how can you
blame it on one particular thing when
it's so many other issues coming
together for this kind of larger
eruption of violence that there's no
going back from no you're absolutely
right but I also think that it's it
comes back down to the base thing we no
longer value human life you don't look
at somebody and they have value so I
mean as a as a as a Christian certain as
an ordinary minister I look at somebody
that value because it created the image
of God so you have value just because
you're a human being we don't have that
anymore that we're moving so far away
from that as a society that we no longer
value somebody exactly well
I mean we're not taught to Value other
people in a very bizarre narcissistic
way we're sort of taught to Value
ourselves everything is me me me me and
do whatever you want or need to do to
get what is going to be pleasurable for
you but there's never any emphasis put
on caring for other people ever and so
when somebody does end up you know you
mentioned poverty and how people will
bring that up and poverty is not really
the best explanation because
there are people in there no no no no
I'm not saying that that's an
explanation you would argue is is the
case or tells the full story but there
are many cultures and even entire
civilizations which are radically
impoverished compared to our extremely
wealthy and abundant society and they
are not acting like barbarians and
stabbing you know children are not
running around stabbing women and men
are not beating up old men on the
streets or you know going into places of
business and just savagely beating
innocent women right
AOC we have the story from uh July of
2020 when she defends the rise in crime
saying people are stealing bread to feed
their children during record
unemployment the aocr it's like people
were getting shot in the streets and she
was like they're trying to steal bread
and it's like they just shot a guy in
front of his daughter they didn't take
anything from like there's no bread
there we're not complaining about the
bread theft no and though and here's the
thing too man the media allows these
radical left people and and really all
politicians but we see the radical lying
to the American people over and over and
over again and there's no accountability
none so we're not holding people
accountable you're not holding
politicians accountable you're not
holding the people accountable Law and
Order is just out the window this is
society Falls like this this is exactly
how Society Falls I think it's a weak
men make hard times yep what we're
seeing is you know you guys are
basically saying it no one cares for
each other there's no sense of community
no because everyone feels like everyone
else is just out to get them or for them
or or get for themselves so they're just
like you know you see these cops in
Uvalde and I these cops refuse to go in
and I'm just like because they're think
they're not thinking about their
Community or the better civilization
they're thinking me
well that or or it's a it's a breakdown
of leadership too um so I mean I I know
law enforcement's in my community and
one of the things that they said was uh
the people inside uh standing in the
stack were actually listening to their
commanding officer who said don't go in
that it shifted but they were an active
shooter it shifted from an active
shooter to a hostage situation so their
their protocol was very different but
that information is not true with the
overall overwhelming amount of evidence
coming forward right now they knew it
was an active shooter they had all the
evidence it was an active shooter and
they were already inside of that school
and then they just left and abandoned
those children there so that's another
aspect it was reported they could hear
the children getting shot yeah it was
reported that I'm not given excuse for
I'm just saying that's that's what I I
that's the public explanation before
they've been lying through their teeth
though from the beginning of this
it's crazy I mean all in the interesting
story in that to me and all of that is
is you're like one mom was arrested yeah
put in handcuffs she got out of the
release from the handcuffs and jumped
the fence jumped the fence rescued their
her two kids and came back I mean and
she reported how there was active
gunshots when the police was telling
everyone that it would there was no
accident
you could hear the gun yeah well it was
a father and and a team that went down
with him with the shield right and then
went and took out the threat after
disobeying orders and finally uh doing
you know the thing that they should have
been doing from the very beginning but
that man also waited over 30 plus
minutes sure scene so
and you're seeing that situation and
people are just waiting but calling for
a change in legislation and calling for
more legislation as a result it just
isn't the right answer because if if
legislation it was actually what fixed
it it wouldn't have happened to start
with there's multiple laws broken you
can't fix cultural problems with policy
nope and I don't see us finding I don't
see there being a way to fix our
cultural problems the world I mean and
you also got to realize too I think and
I think I said it yesterday we can never
allow times of tragedy to dictate policy
because every time you do that you're
just opening up the future opportunity
for people to actually create the
tragedy to strip you of whatever rights
or freedoms you want next I think oh
that's what's happening with the gun
control debate yeah totally it's like
we're all shocked so we're saying do
something do what do something if you
don't have a plan the meme is Keep Calm
and Carry On Not freak out and just do
something right no do something is not
always the answer Thomas Macy had some
very good tweets about the legislation
that they're proposing and the counter
evidence to it on his public Twitter
account that I think is worth
considering and looking at especially
when it comes to the latest political
debates surrounding this very hot button
issue and and he made a lot of very good
points so um if you look at so
historically while you're looking at it
so historically look at prior to 1970
there wasn't a decade if I'm if I
numbers are right there's not a decade
there was more than 10 mass shootings
okay so I think in 1950 there was one
1960 there was six 1970 there's 13 I
think it was 32 and 42. so to me I
always want to look at what's the root
cause the root cause around all of that
was a absolutely a cultural shift so
like in 62-63 they took prayer and
bibles out of schools and 70s that was
when Roe v Wade happened and so you're
having all this stuff going on with
abortions so as a society our values
shifted drastically during that time
it's not actually this late 60s and 70s
it's the generation before because the
Boomers were raised by a generation
right they they had those values once
they grew up they enacted those values
what we're seeing now with Millennials
in wokeness where values instilled in
them when they were like 10 right I
remember being young having all of the
teachers talk about you know racism
being bad and civil rights and we have
to learn that the true history of civil
rights and everything well for them
the older generation that that raises us
they live through it they experience say
oh I get it
you then raise a younger generation on
on telling them you must fight racism
what happens when they grow up and most
of these policies have already been made
illegal they're looking for it as hard
as they can because they were raised in
this world
one of the things that really impacted
everybody
was uh imagine you're 10 years old in
2008.
and uh you're on Facebook it looks like
2012 let's say 10 years ago you're 10
years old say you're eight years old and
on Facebook all you're seeing are videos
of police brutality yeah because that
was making people money and the
algorithm kept promoting it yep
if that's the only thing you see your
whole world growing up yeah from 8 to 18
was watching videos of police brutality
you turn 18 and you're freaking out
you're like I have to vote to stop this
algorithm
right I mean the police are hunting
black people
right like yo calm down dude when the
reality is the vast majority of all law
enforcement are great people they're
willing to put themselves between you
and then he's up anybody that wants you
harm once you wish you harm and that's
that's a huge thing we have to advocate
for our police gen Z is going to be the
algorithm generation Millennials grew up
half and half When We Were Young we
didn't we had the internet but we didn't
have these algorithms we get into our
you know early 20s or whatever late 20s
and now we have these these algorithms
manipulating our views but half of our
lives are still built upon the previous
non-social media infrastructure gen Z is
basically growing up in
algorithmic an algorithmic World their
adult lives are all algorithmic gen
Alpha 100 of it is right so their worlds
are all going to be completely
controlled by the whims of Mark
Zuckerberg and Jack Dorsey and and
YouTube yep when the Boomers and the Gen
xers age out this country is going to go
into full-on conflict or chaos violence
just you name it
it'll be interesting to see the shift
there'll definitely be a shift
um but I actually think that I actually
think the way especially right now as
radical as because their left isn't no
longer they're not liberals I know
liberals they're now radicals are
running the Democrat Party right so I
actually think that they're going to
create a generation of truly
conservative people well that's that's
what I believe so maybe I think the
bigger issue is that conservatives have
kids in the left doesn't and if the left
doesn't win the fight but it's true I
mean it's scientifically it's very true
if the left doesn't win the fight in
schools then they are gone right like
literally within a couple generations
and people are pulling their kids out of
school right they put them in private
school or they're going homeschooling
which I wouldn't I would advocate for it
this is it right here if if you
homeschool your kids that's it
is every single
post-liberal moderate Centrist
libertarian conservative said I'm gonna
homeschool my kids within three
generations all the left is gone oh yeah
completely so what people don't
understand these big shifts you
mentioned like in the 70s with Roe v
Wade what's really happening is that
power is held by people in society that
power is used to control and and spread
messages or enact policy typically the
older generation controls a
disproportionate amount of wealth right
now Boomers control more wealth than the
previous generation did when they were
the same age as Millennials basically
Millennials should be holding I think
like 20 or 30 of wealth they hold like
three Boomers hold like 25 or something
I was reading some report on this
what's going to happen is boomers are
going to slowly start dying they're
getting old
when they do that wealth and power will
transfer to a millennial or to a gen xer
probably from a boomer to a to a
millennial maybe some younger zenial
types people who are in their early 40s
when that starts happening that power
will be wielded as per the ideology of
younger people and these younger people
according to the splc favor political
assassinations more so so if a billion
dollars is held by someone who's 80
years old they're not going to be
spending it towards extremism right if
they die and that wealth transfers to
their five young heirs who are more
likely to believe in violence that
wealth will now be utilized in that
direction it's not that a society over
time decides like a lot of people think
that there's a guy named Bob and Bob one
day turns on the YouTube and goes wow I
have been radicalized and then grabs a
tiki torch and goes outside what really
happens is that Bob sees the YouTube
videos and goes wow that's crazy and
then Bob tells his kid and he says you
see this stuff man life shouldn't be
this way then that kid grows up grabs a
tiki torch and goes outside right it's
when the older generation dies off that
that shift we see isn't that Society has
decided something like a person's mind
changed it's that the people of certain
values no longer live and the power
transfers to those of different ideas
yep that's why I advocate for values
values exactly Faith Family Freedom
these are the three things that I think
that are that are building blocks for
our society historically is what it made
us a great nation if we come back to
those things I really do believe that's
the hope for our future is there any way
to politically achieve those how would
what kind of things would you propose
legislation or action plans that would
help bring that forward well first I
mean I do I would absolutely put forth
legislation codifying parental rights
saying that parents have rights of their
children's medical and education
decisions and in that in that I think
that the money for Education should
follow the student so whether a parent
decides they're going to go to public
school they go to a private school
they're going to homeschool whatever
that money is that goes to those
students that credit goes to that
student yeah New Hampshire already does
this it should I mean and it should be
federally yeah I mean federally that
should happen if we're going to put
money in to the government because we
want to take care of the education of
our children they should follow our kids
wherever they go of course that makes
sense to me well Donald Trump proposed
the voucher system right yeah I
absolutely agree with yeah 100 I don't
know if it's the you know the the true
uh like the one solution to helping kids
with schools and fixing the school
problems but I mean dissolving the
Department of Education and pushing that
down to the state levels is a huge start
yes yeah yeah also I mean look it's not
just the fact that children would no
longer be indoctrinated in the same way
if parents had any choice about where
they could send their children's to
school children to school but also we
would probably end up achieving at a
higher level with respect to education
generally speaking if schools had to
compete for students and so what the
left will say when they argue against uh
school choice and this is such an
unbelievable self-owned but they'll say
you only advocate for school choice
because you want to bankrupt Public
Schools all right well you're admitting
parents would send their kid anywhere
else if they had a choice yeah the
public schools are that bad make them
better exactly so it's like well school
choice wouldn't be a threat if we had
public schools which were decently run
and you wanted to put the effort into
making them function decently parents
should have a choice for their kids
public schools are a net negative on
your children yeah 100 parents don't
want their children indoctrinated they
if they want your child we want our
children to be educated the basics you
know what you're reading writing
arithmetic I mean stem studies these are
the basic things that we want for our
kids we don't want them indoctrinated
growing up honestly I mean I did not
know where most of my teachers landed
politically
and that's how it should be
you're there to teach me a subject and
that's it help me learn let me learn how
to learn
rather than just shoving something down
my throat that's what we want for our
kids we don't want them indoctrinated
but that's what's happening it is 100
what's that happening and for a lot of
people it's not as easy just get your
kids out of school because no it's
expensive well it's basically daycare
right well yeah there is that but it's
also expensive all of these things are
are you know connected to each other
when women enter the workforce
at first it was you can work if you want
to which is true and correct equal
opportunity but then all of a sudden the
workforce doubles and now some guy goes
to apply for a job and the boss says
look this guy over here he's got a wife
who's working he doesn't need as much
money right I'm not going to pay you
what you're asking for and the guy says
okay I'll go down now all of a sudden
the guy comes home and says honey I got
the job bad news you need to start
working because we're not gonna have
enough money right now she's working
who's raising the kids they got to go to
daycare fortunately Public Schools they
can drop their kids off and say someone
else will take care of it the more
workers the more you're able to pay them
less because there's more competition
for that market and this is why uh you
know there's individuals like David
Rockefeller that were huge proponents of
of this larger movement when it came to
allowing women to to to work because he
knew that it would allow him in his
factories and his businesses to earn a
lot more money and I think that's
another aspect to really understand here
especially with his kind of formation of
the education system that we're under
right now what we need is POD schooling
yeah you know I hear it's we were
talking with one of our guests that was
not that easy but uh women can and
should be at work if they want to be I
think equal opportunity is fantastic and
then your kids if you need someone to
watch them you shouldn't put them in an
institutionalized learning facility
where you don't know the teachers you
should get someone you know and trust
have them come together for your
community and teach this you know this
one person can do it all I want to I
just want to make this point there's a
great quote from Chesterton he said that
feminism is the modeled idea that women
are free when they serve their employers
and slaves when they serve their
husbands and I wanted to say it is
correct that women should be allowed to
do whatever they want but I think that
the cultural imperative right now is
that women should want to be cogs in the
machine like Chesterton talks about
they're told that they should want to
serve an employer not be a slave to
their children and you can listen to The
Narrative that moms nowadays have about
their kids or like I can't stand being
around my kids I can imagine how you
homeschool I'm so glad when they leave
for the day and it's like why did you
have children what was your thinking you
obviously aren't in the right mindset to
be like okay I want to raise kids here's
what I'm going to do it's really
important to bring them up correctly
they just hand them off to the nearest
person which tends to be the state it's
a huge problem I hate the mindset and I
hate that the culture has made it so
that women are incentivized to leave
their families and go back to work we
don't see children as a gift anymore
either right you know I mean one of my
honestly one of my favorite things is
being a father you know I really see
once a great responsibility to raise up
a human being to take over into society
but to me I think that we have to see
children as a gift that's what they are
that is the next Generation that's who's
going to take over the country he's
going to take over the world it's a it's
such a huge responsibility but a huge
privilege to get to raise somebody and
teach them and guide them I got an idea
for a form of government where the law
is applied to you as you wish it to be
applied to others that's it simple there
you go you know so if you're someone
who's like I think violence is wrong
then if someone commits violent to get
violence against you then you that
person will be criminally charged if you
commit violence against someone else you
will be criminally charged if someone
else say like an antifa person says well
I believe it's Justified then someone
comes and fights you we there's no lot
to be applied because you don't find a
problem with it right I mean I'm half
kidding but you get the idea right yeah
it's interesting go ahead oh no I just
want to piggyback on something you said
because you know you're a father you
have children I don't but one thing that
I have always found very sad about this
culture is just the way having children
is viewed it's strange because people
will point out that having kids is hard
work and then they'll say therefore it's
not worth it but we don't really do that
with anything else I mean we're starting
to in some areas but imagine only like
well I don't want to become rich because
being rich is hard work only suckers do
hard work but that's basically the
attitude that our society has cultivated
when it comes to children it's like
right well it's it's hard work so screw
that why do it but it's that is actually
that does carry over into everything I
think it started too so I've seen it so
as a small business owner I've had so
many people go oh man you're really
lucky what do you mean really lucky yeah
sacrifice years of my life do you know
me do you know me how much times I miss
with my parents with my kids or with my
parents how much time I've missed with
my family in order to be able to and
luckily we do a lot of it together as a
family you know as far as building out
our studio everything else but there are
some things you're just going to spend
time away from your family in order to
do it so it's not just this oh you just
get it so but people aren't willing to
do the hard work same thing with kids
though it's they're seen as a sacrifice
oh that's awesome give up what are you
talking about this is such a gift that
you get to have influence in somebody
else's life and you get to guide them in
life it's such a good and think about
once they're you know like nine years
old and they can start washing the
dishes
I remember the first time that my oldest
son cut the grass I took a picture I
sent it to my dad I was like oh this is
what it was all about right you made it
son yeah
whenever I see someone work really hard
at something I admire it and so like as
someone without kids when I see someone
with kids who's working hard to raise
that what it says to me is if they're
willing to put that kind of effort in it
must really be worth it it is but for
whatever reason we don't look at things
that way anymore we see someone putting
hard work and we go oh they're a sucker
they're putting hard work in instead of
saying well maybe they're putting hard
work in because there's a significant
reward here there's something bigger
than that they're missing out another
huge problem with the millennial
generation and the younger is the
entitlement sure no no no hard work I
hear it all the time if only I had X
then I could do it if only I had money
and I'm just like wow as an employer I
can tell you that that's true yeah you
know I mean and and I value somebody
that's willing to do the hard work I
tell my boys all the time I said listen
in the future when you're in the working
class if you will show up on time just
simply do your job and have a good
attitude you'll be a superstar
yep that's it thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there